Let's say we want to know how a song about the content are used to teach the
content might impact engagement. We're going to set up for a hypothesis test,
which will compare our current population with what we predict will be our new
population after this treatment or intervention. Remember, in a hypothesis
test, we have the null hypothesis and the alternative hypothesis. And the null
is that there's no significant difference between the population after the
intervention is given and the current population parameter. And the alternative
could be one of three things, that the current population is less than what it
will be after the intervention, that it's greater, or that it's just different.
In this example, what could the null hypothesis be? Check all that apply.